nouveau rétropédalage de l'exécutif face
à la pandémie
lors de l'inauguration du centre de
vaccination de la porte de versailles à
paris hier emmanuel macron s'est dit
favorable à la levée des brevets je suis
tout à fait favorable à ce qu'il y ait
en effet cette ouverture de la propriété
intellectuelle vous m'avez entendu de
dire il ya un an quand nous avons dans
ses initiatives
une position adoptée depuis un an selon
le président de la république pourtant
il ya un peu plus d'un mois
clément bonne le secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes affirme
l inverse
nous partageons votre objectif c'est
d'ailleurs la france et celles qui ont
de la république qui l'ont porté en
premier chef du vaccin un bien public
mondial
maintenant il faut sortir des slogans
pour atteindre cet objectif
si élevé les brevets avait une
quelconque utilité aujourd'hui nous le
ferions immédiatement mais ça ne sert à
rien aujourd'hui
je le dis très clairement une ligne de
conduite maintenu jusqu'au parlement
européen
le 28 avril dernier l'ensemble des
eurodéputés de la république en marche
voté contre l'amendement en faveur de la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins un
changement de cap radical donc du
gouvernement
dénoncé par la france insoumise pape
haydn à part les minima qu'on s'aligne
victoire totale pour nous tous qui nous
sommes mobilisés dans le monde entier
pour les licences libres sur les vaccins
hypocrite emmanuel macron vous êtes
battu contre cette levée des brevets sur
le vaccin pour servir vos amis du fric
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
la france a voté contre à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
vdn vous inspire par fait taxer les
riches le principal intéressé a tenu à
clarifier la situation sur son compte
twitter je maintiens françois ruffin
lever les brevets n'a pas d'impact à
court terme c'est autorisé l'export qui
est urgent l'europe exporte 50 % de sa
production
les etats unis 0 c'est nous qui livrons
les pays qui en ont besoin
si vous défendiez la solidarité vous
devriez en être fier un débat qui
pourrait très bien s'inviter dans les
discussions entre états membres de
l'union européenne qui se réunissent ce
vendredi à porto